Prof: Good morning, all.
The title of today's lecture
is, "The Roman Way of Life
and Death at Ostia,
the Port of Rome."
On Tuesday we spoke about
architecture under the emperor
Hadrian, the extraordinary
emperor Hadrian.
We talked about the buildings
that he commissioned,
and some of which he also had a
hand in designing since,
as we mentioned,
he was an amateur architect
himself.
We spoke about that Greek
import, the Temple of Venus and
Roma,
and also about the two major
commissions during his
principate,
the Pantheon in Rome and
Hadrian's Villa at Tivoli.
The main takeaway point
vis-à-vis both of these
buildings--
and you see them once again now
on the screen,
at left and right--is that
Hadrian followed the lead of
Trajan before him.
What Trajan had done,
and Apollodorus of Damascus had
done,
in the Forum of Trajan and in
the Markets of Trajan,
and that is to combine,
in one building complex,
both the traditional and the
innovative strands of Roman
architecture.
The traditional that goes back
to Greek and Etruscan
architecture and is marked by
the traditional elements,
the traditional vocabulary of
architecture,
namely columns and walls and
the roofs that they support;
and then more innovative Roman
architecture,
which is predicated on concrete
construction,
faced with a variety of
materials, from stone to what
we'll see today as the
ascendance of brick as a facing,
which began,
as you'll recall,
after the fire in A.D.
64 in Rome.
Again, looking at these two
buildings as examples of what
Hadrian, he and his architects,
tried to do.
The Pantheon,
you'll recall on the left,
has a traditional porch,
a porch that looks very much
like a typical Greek,
Etruscan or Roman temple,
but then a revolutionary body,
when you walk inside the
building, a revolutionary
cylindrical drum and
hemispherical dome.
And then with regard to
Hadrian's Villa at Tivoli,
I show you a view of the
Canopus, and you'll recall that
the Canopus makes use of
columnar architecture.
There are columns that border
one end of the pool,
although they are columns with
a twist because you can see they
support a straight and an
arcuated lintel,
which we saw in Second Style
Roman wall painting,
in painting,
and then eventually it begins
to infiltrate built
architecture,
comes to the fore under Hadrian.
So that's a playing around with
those lintels in a way you
wouldn't have seen in Greek and
Etruscan architecture,
but still relies,
in the main,
on the traditional vocabulary
of architecture.
But then you'll recall,
on the other end of the pool,
a building that was meant to
conjure up the Serapeum in the
Temple of Serapis in Canopus,
in Egypt, but that was made out
of concrete construction and
that had a segmented dome,
a kind of pumpkin dome that we
believe that Hadrian designed
himself.
So this extraordinary
combination of traditional and
innovative Roman architecture;
that we see the hallmark of
Hadrianic architecture,
and a gift that he gave to the
future evolution of
architecture.
The other major contribution of
the Hadrianic period,
that Hadrian himself had less
to do with because it was
already bubbling up after the
fire in A.D.
64, is the move that we're
going to see today toward
multi-storied housing.
We saw that begin already at
the last gasp of Pompeii and
Herculaneum.
You'll remember after the
earthquake of 62,
and before the eruption of
Vesuvius,
the Pompeians and those who
lived in Herculaneum began to
build,
began to add additional stories
to their residential structures,
and that meant for the most
part a second story being added
to their residential structures,
but they never went beyond that.
What we see beginning to
happen, especially under
Hadrian,
is an increased taste for
multi-storied buildings,
multi-storied domiciles,
but multi-storied residences
that had more than two stories,
even up to as many as five
stories: essentially apartment
houses.
And our best example for such
apartment houses are in the city
of Ostia,
the port city of Rome,
and it's therefore to the city
of Ostia that we are going to
turn to today.
And, in fact,
we'll spend the entire lecture
on the city of Ostia,
because like Pompeii and
Herculaneum before it,
especially like Pompeii,
we have an extraordinary array
of not only private domiciles,
but also public architecture
from the city of Ostia that
gives us an outstanding sense of
what this city looked like in
antiquity.
I show you a plan of Ostia in
its heyday.
You'll remember that the city
was actually founded very early
on.
At the very beginning of the
semester, we looked at the town
plan of Ostia,
which dated to the mid-fourth
century B.C.,
around 350 B.C.
And you'll recall--and I'll
remind you of this plan in a
moment--
you'll recall that it was
founded as--
it was actually Rome's first
colony,
although it was a colony in
Italy obviously,
not outside the mainland,
but its first colony in Italy,
or anywhere for that matter.
And it was founded,
as so many of these first
colonies were,
as a military camp.
It was laid out as a
castrum,
as you'll recall.
And that castrum,
one can see in the very
center--
I'm going to show you a better
view of this from Ward-Perkins
in a moment--
but you can see that kernel of
the castrum plan right
here in the center of this plan.
But what this plan shows you is
the way in which the city grew
over time.
Again, it began in the
Republic, it continued to be
developed during the Republic.
It was under Augustus that some
new buildings,
some public buildings were
added to the locale,
including the Theater,
and we're going to look at the
Theater today.
And then ports were added,
as you'll remember--and I'll
review that momentarily--ports
were added at Portus,
by Claudius and also by Trajan.
And it was after the Port of
Trajan that the city really
began to take off in terms of
its commercial activity,
and much of the building that
we see in the city,
as it looks still today,
belongs to the Hadrianic period
and into the time of the
successors of Hadrian,
the so-called Antonine
emperors, whose architecture
we'll also be studying this
semester.
While this plan is on the
screen, let me just point out
the location of Rome--
the arrow points this way--the
so-called Via Ostiense,
the route, the street that
leads from Rome to Ostia;
the Via Ostiense.
And actually the city road
becomes the town--the country
road;
the country thoroughfare
becomes the city street,
the main city street,
the decumanus of the
city of Ostia.
You can also see in this plan
the location of a place called
Isola Sacra, up there,
which we will see was the main
cemetery for Ostia.
Yes, there are tombs outside
the city walls,
also elsewhere in the city,
but our most- best-preserved
tombs are from this area called
Isola Sacra;
and I'll show that to you also
today.
And here you can see the Tiber
River, the Tevere,
the Tiber River wending its way
from Rome to Ostia.
And it is of course along the
Tiber that we'll see warehouses
were located,
and where the ships went back
and forth to export or import
material,
products from Rome to Ostia and
back again.
Again, we talked about the
building of ports at Ostia.
We talked especially about the
port that Claudius commissioned,
at Portus, and I remind you of
it on the back of a Neronian
coin, a coin of Nero;
obverse with Nero's portrait,
reverse representing that
Claudian port.
And we see it there.
You'll remember it had curved
breakwaters, which you can see
in that coin depiction,
and a river god at the bottom;
boats in the center,
as well as the lighthouse.
We see all of that on the coin.
And you'll remember that the
breakwaters were made up of
columns that partook of that
rusticated masonry that Claudius
so favored.
Down here, a painting that I've
shown you before,
that is on the walls of the
Vatican in Rome,
the Vatican Museums in Rome,
where you can see Claudius'
port,
with its curved breakwaters and
its lighthouse over here.
And then the port that was
added by Trajan during his
reign, a multi-sided additional
port right here.
And it was again the
construction of that particular
port that really brought
commerce even more--
this area had been used since
the mid-fourth century B.C.,
but it begins to really take
off;
there's a real efflorescence
during this period.
And it is therefore not
surprising that with commerce
booming there was more need for
residential architecture,
for those who lived there,
for the traders and so on and
so forth who lived there,
and we see this,
the building of not only civic
buildings but especially of
private domiciles begins to move
very rapidly apace.
The city becomes more crowded
and there becomes this need to
build up vertically,
as well as horizontally;
and we'll see that development
today.
Tourists who go to Rome really
miss the boat by not going out
to Ostia in larger numbers,
because most tourists don't
tend to take the trip out to
Ostia.
But it's well worth it,
and it's very easy to get to.
It only takes about 25 minutes
to a half an hour on a suburban
train, to get from Rome to
Ostia.
So it's a not-to-be-missed
experience.
And I show you one of these
trains in the upper left that
takes you very easily from Rome
to the site of Ostia.
There are a number of stations
in Ostia.
One of them is Ostia Centro,
the downtown of Ostia,
which you see in that view in
the upper left.
And the other is Lido di Ostia,
which means "the
beach," and I show you a
view of Lido di Ostia down here.
Now looking at that nice view
of the ocean--
I know you've all been,
you're back from spring break,
but still it's nice to
reminisce about what some of you
may have been doing during
spring break and see this
wonderful view of the scene.
It looks very enticing,
but I can tell you that it's
not, once you get there.
It's very polluted.
This is not one of the great
beaches of the world.
So don't be seduced by Lido di
Ostia.
Stay on the train and make your
way to the site called Scavi di
Ostia,
which is the excavations of
Ostia, the archaeological
excavations,
where you can see,
as you saw, as one sees in
Pompeii,
an ancient Roman city,
extremely well preserved.
And you see a glimpse of it
over here, and you can tell even
just from this glimpse that we
are dealing here with a city
that is not unlike Pompeii.
It has streets and sidewalks,
and it has buildings along the
side of either of those.
But there is one main
difference between this and what
we saw at Pompeii--
and you can see it very well in
this image--
and that is that these houses,
that are along the street,
look different than those did
in Pompeii in that they are made
out of concrete,
faced with brick:
a very different kind of
appearance,
and one that is
quintessentially Ostian and
makes this city well worth a
visit.
In fact, if we think of Pompeii
as the quintessential
first-century A.D.
Roman city, we should think of
the city of Ostia as the
quintessential second-century
A.D.
city, the best example that we
have of what a second century,
a Hadrianic and Antonine city,
would have looked like,
and that is what makes it so
important to us.
Here I remind you again of the
original plan that we looked at,
the plan from the mid-fourth
century B.C.,
350 B.C., from Ward-Perkins,
that shows you the original
castrum of the first
colony: this rectangular space,
very regular,
with its own wall surrounding
the city,
with the cardo,
the north-south street,
and the decumanus,
the east-west street,
intersecting exactly at the
center of that city.
And then at that intersection,
as was Roman practice,
the placement of the forum of
the city,
a great open rectangular space
with a temple pushed up against
the back wall,
in this case a Temple of
Jupiter, a Capitolium,
dominating the space in front
of it,
and then other buildings around
it,
as you can see.
Although there's a striking
difference between this forum
and the forum that we saw at
Pompeii,
because you'll remember at
Pompeii the various major
buildings,
the Basilica,
the Temple of Apollo,
and so on, sort of radiating
out from the central core of the
forum.
We don't see that here.
We see the buildings sort of
placed separately,
from that main forum space.
But in every other respect very
similar to the general plan of
these early Roman cities .
What's also useful about this
particular plan is the fact that
it shows you the way,
as time went by and as the city
grew,
it shows you the way in which
the cardo and the
decumanus were extended,
and then the other buildings of
the city were added here and
there: a number of baths;
lots of private residences.
This is a particularly
important building here at 15
and 16,
which we'll look at today:
15 is the Theater and 16 is the
so-called Piazza of the
Corporations,
the Piazzale delle
Corporazioni,
which is very significant,
and we'll look at that soon.
If you go and visit the city of
Ostia today,
and enter at the ticket booth,
what you see almost immediately
is again a polygonal masonry
street,
looking very much like Pompeii.
But once again there are no
stepping stones in Ostia,
unlike Pompeii -- the plot
thickens there in terms of why
we see those in Pompeii and
don't seem to see them anywhere
else.
You walk along that polygonal
masonry street pavement and you
see both the remains up here in
the upper left of the original
Republican city wall,
and it should bring back
memories of opus
quadratum,
or ashlar masonry,
that we saw at the beginning of
the semester.
You can see it's consistent
with the age in which it was
built in the Republic.
But then over here,
as you make your way along on
one of the main streets,
you see what is characteristic
of Ostia as a whole,
and that is concrete
construction,
brick-faced concrete
both for the residences and
also for the public buildings,
and also for the religious
structures,
namely the temples in this city.
The reason for this,
of course--it takes us back to
the Neronian period,
the great fire of 64,
when it was realized --
you'll remember the Subura,
which was located back beyond
the precinct walls of the Forum
of Augustus,
the area where the working poor
of Rome lived,
primarily in rickety apartment
houses that were made out of
wood;
multi-storied houses.
Those were actually
multi-storied,
but they were always going up
in flames,
and there was a recognition
after the great destruction of
the fire of 64 that the Romans
needed to fireproof their
buildings,
and they recognized the fact
that brick is better at
protecting the structure from
fire than stone is,
and stone can burn,
and they actually began to--
as we know, we talked about
this before--
they began to build their
houses and many of their civic
structures out of concrete faced
with brick.
And we see that development
especially well here in Ostia.
And Ostia is extremely
important for us also because
many comparable buildings that
were put up in the city of Rome
itself no longer survive.
The same apartment houses that
we're going to see at Ostia did
exist in Rome.
We have some remains of them.
There's a very prominent one at
the base of the Capitoline Hill,
to the left of the hill as you
climb up that hill.
But we have very little
evidence for this in Rome,
and so we have to rely on Ostia
to give us the best picture of
apartment building in Rome,
in Roman architecture in the
second century A.D.
Here is a spectacular view of
Ostia as it looks today,
from the air,
and we are obviously looking
down on the forum,
on the great open rectangular
space of the forum,
with columns around it.
We are looking also at the
Capitolium,
at the Temple of Jupiter,
which is a very large
structure,
as you can see here,
made out of concrete,
faced with brick.
It is a typical Roman temple,
unlike Hadrian's Temple of
Venus and Roma,
because we can see that it has
a façade orientation;
it has a single staircase;
it has a deep porch,
freestanding columns in that
porch.
So a typical Roman structure
and--it's a typical Roman
temple.
And then you can also see its
vast scale.
There are a couple of people
standing here who look miniscule
in relationship to this
building,
and only part of the building,
in fact the full height of the
building,
is not even preserved here.
So it was even larger still
than what you see.
The reason for its size is
twofold: one,
because we have already seen
that this taste for larger and
larger buildings has really
taken off.
We saw it in Hadrian's Forum in
Rome.
We saw it in Domitian's Palace
on the Palatine Hill.
We saw it in Hadrian's Villa at
Tivoli, and in the Pantheon,
the largest span,
the largest dome ever built.
So this taste for largeness,
grandiosity in architecture,
has really taken off.
So it's not surprising to see
this Capitolium,
which was built in the
Hadrianic period,
specifically 120 A.D.,
also being large in scale.
But there's a second and
perhaps even more important
reason,
and that is in a city in which
all of the--
most of the houses are what are
called insulae--
i-n-s-u-l-a in the singular;
a-e in the
plural--insulae,
multi-storied apartment
buildings, often of as many as
five stories.
If you want your Capitolium to
stand out in that city,
and be seen up above those
apartment houses,
you've got to build it very
high.
And that is undoubtedly the
reason that they--
one of the two reasons,
the more important reason--
that they have built this
temple so large,
and especially so tall,
so that you could see the
Temple of Jupiter from
everywhere in the city of Ostia.
Here's a view of the Temple as
it looks today in isolation,
again, only part of its height
preserved,
but enough for us to get a very
good sense of its concrete
construction,
brick facing here,
and as I've already described,
the single staircase,
the columns in the porch and so
on.
I mentioned already that it was
under Augustus that a theater
and an entertainment district
was added to the city of Ostia,
and that building,
you see the remains of it here,
along one of the major streets
of the city of Ostia.
It was renovated in around 200
A.D.;
that is, in the early part of
the third century A.D.,
so considerably later.
It was expanded to be able to
hold 2,500 spectators at that
particular point,
and much of the concrete and
brick-faced construction belongs
to that renovation.
One can't imagine a building
quite like this in the age of
Augustus.
So what you're seeing here is
primarily the restored view,
the restored version of this
building.
But what you can see,
that does at least link it back
to the Augustan period,
is the fact that the design of
the façade is very
similar to the design of the
Theater of Marcellus in Rome,
with the arches,
and in this case pilasters
between them --
that same general scheme that
we saw for theater and for
amphitheater architecture,
used here.
The main difference,
of course, is the fact that we
have concrete construction with
brick facing,
rather than concrete
construction with stone facing,
travertine in the case of the
Theater of Marcellus.
I haven't yet shown you a Roman
latrine, but today is the day
for the Roman latrine.
But you have to imagine,
of course,
that in any major public
building, like a theater,
where you're going to have a
lot of people there at the same
time,
you have to provide a public
latrine.
And when I say a public
latrine, I really mean a public
latrine.
There was no privacy,
as you can see,
in this latrine whatsoever.
What it is composed of,
as you can see,
is a bench that lines the
walls, with a series of holes in
it,
and then just one single drain
that encircles the building.
So this gives you an idea of
where you had to go,
if you needed to go,
during intermission,
if you were attending the
Theater in Ostia.
One of the most important
buildings at Ostia is connected
to this Theater.
I'm showing you now the plan of
the Theater, which corresponds
to theaters that we've looked at
throughout this semester;
a typical Roman plan.
It has a semi-circular
orchestra.
It has a stage building or
scaenae frons here.
It has a semicircular
cavea,
the seats, which are placed on
top of, of course in this case,
a concrete foundation.
This, like other Roman
theaters, is an urban
phenomenon.
There was no hill to build this
on,
so the Romans had to build--the
Ostians had to build their own
hill out of concrete,
and then support the
cavea on top of that.
But the cavea is made of
stone seats;
they used stone for the seats,
as is traditional in Roman
theater architecture.
But we see that this Theater is
appended to a porticus.
Now we've seen a
porticus with these
theaters before;
it was in fact characteristic
of theater design.
And if you think back to the
Theater in Pompeii,
for example,
you'll remember that that
porticus,
which had little shops all
around it,
or small cubicles all around
it, was used as a place where
you could go during intermission
to relax,
to walk around,
to buy a playbill,
to pick up a souvenir T-shirt
or whatever the equivalent was
in those days:
a souvenir of your experience
that evening at the theater.
And so we see that same general
scheme here,
this whole idea of this open
rectangular space,
with some columns,
and then with these little
cubicles all along.
But in this case it was not
meant to be a place for
souvenirs or a place to store
props.
But instead what we see is
something quite fascinating,
given the fact that the city of
Ostia was primarily a commercial
city,
a place where items were
exported and imported.
Because it was a major port or
harbor city,
what this was used for
instead--hence its name the
Piazzale delle Corporazioni--
is a series of businesses that
were--
the import/export business
essentially is what these spaces
were used for.
And I'll show you.
Actually some of them are quite
well preserved and I can show
you indeed what they looked
like.
Then in the center something we
also don't see in the Pompeii
Theater,
a small temple in the center,
a temple that corresponds to
Roman temples that we've looked
at thus far: its rectangular
shape;
its flat side and back walls;
some columns in the deep porch;
a single staircase;
façade emphasis,
as you can see here;
relatively small in scale,
as these kinds of things go.
And it has been speculated by
the main excavator of this site
that it was used as a--that it
was dedicated to some god whose
name we don't know;
we don't know which god or
goddess this was dedicated to.
But the excavator has
speculated that it was probably
some god that had something to
do with commerce,
and the blessing of commerce,
and that probably some trade
guild,
one of the trade guilds that
had its businesses set up here,
may have been the
commissioners,
may have paid for,
indeed commissioned this
particular temple.
And I think that's as good a
theory as any,
and may well be the case.
This is a view--we're standing
at the top of the cavea,
looking down over that
cavea.
We can see the cunei or
wedge-shaped sections of seats.
We can see the stone that has
been used for those seats.
We can see the semicircular
orchestra,
the scalloped face of the
stage, and then one can imagine
the scaenae frons,
with its forest of columns
behind;
that part is not well preserved.
And there also would have
been--I'll show you a restored
view a little bit later where
you'll see that there was a much
higher wall in between this and
the Piazzale that lay beyond.
The wall is no longer there,
so we can see very well through
these columns,
the small temple that was put
up by that trade guild,
to some god of commerce.
And then we can also see these
cubicles all along the way,
that were used as these import
and export emporia.
This is a view of the temple as
it looks today.
We can see that single
staircase, fairly narrow
staircase here;
the façade orientation;
a couple of the columns,
including a Corinthian column,
that are still preserved from
that small structure.
And then here a very useful
view showing us again these
interesting spaces,
rectangular spaces along here,
fronted in each case by
columns.
We'll see that those columns
are made out of cement,
faced with brick -- so shades
of the Sanctuary of Hercules at
Tivoli.
We haven't seen this before,
I mean, since then.
And that was a very unusual
view.
Here we're seeing something
that actually becomes more
common in the second century,
making concrete columns and
then facing them with brick.
I'd like to show you a few
views of these import/export
businesses, as I've called them;
one of them here,
where we can see that the
architecture itself,
the walls and the columns are
only partially preserved.
You have to imagine that in
antiquity they went up higher
than this.
But what is well preserved are
the mosaics on the floor of each
of these, or many of these
spaces.
And you can see they're all
done in black-and-white mosaic,
just the two colors.
You can see the interest that
the Ostians had in geometric
shapes.
They have inside these very
abstract, inside the shop here,
these abstract patterns,
although they've made an
attempt to vary them.
But then in the front,
something very interesting,
that we see throughout,
is the use of sea imagery.
Because again they were in the
import and export business,
they were busy sending ships
back and forth,
from Italy to other parts of
the Roman world by sea,
and so it's almost all sea
imagery.
Here we see two heraldic
dolphins--dolphins are
particularly popular in these
scenes--
facing one another,
as a kind of advertisement or
shop sign for this particular
enterprise.
Here's another one,
where you can see--I like this
dolphin in particular;
he's nicely preserved and he
has a wonderful serpentine tail,
with a lot of flourish at the
end here, as you can see.
And then inside an image of a
boat;
you can see it's partially
preserved.
What's wonderful about this
example is it shows us that
although these are fairly simple
in design,
and are meant essentially as
advertisements for the shop,
the artist and the patron have
taken real care to think about
what you're going to see when
you're standing where.
So that they have oriented
these so that when you're facing
the shop and deciding whether
you're going to pick this one--
there's 61 of these,
by the way, around the
perimeter of this structure,
so you had a lot of choice,
in terms of which enterprise
you were going to,
where you were going to go to.
If you wanted to ship something
from Ostia somewhere else,
or receive a delivery,
you had a lot of choices.
Although I don't doubt some of
them specialized in different
parts of the world,
shipping to Egypt or shipping
to Asia Minor.
But you can see here the
dolphin.
When you're standing,
deciding whether you want to go
in, the dolphin,
you face the dolphin.
Once you're inside,
and standing and talking to the
owner, if you turn around and
look back, you're going to see
the boat head on.
So they've really--they've
orchestrated this in such
a--they've paid real attention;
it's not done willy-nilly,
they've paid attention to what
you're going to see where,
when you are entering and
inside these spaces.
Here's another one,
not only dolphins,
dolphins, dolphins,
more dolphins and more
dolphins,
but you also see in this case a
lighthouse,
which could either be a
representation of their local
lighthouse,
or some lighthouse somewhere
else that this particular place
ships to.
And then the last one,
which is the one on your
Monument List,
with two boats.
So again, how does one ship
things from Ostia elsewhere?
By boat, and so they tend to
represent boats.
So you've kind of seen it all;
dolphins, boats and lighthouses
tend to be the items that are
chosen for these so-called
advertisements.
But this one is very useful too
because you can see the shapes
and the colors of the
tesserae that are used
here.
And although these are very
effective, you can see that this
is not the Alexander Mosaic;
these are not done with that
kind of skill.
They use only black and white,
the simplest possible scheme,
no colors, and you don't get
the sense,
as you do with something like
the Alexander Mosaic,
when you step back from it,
it could almost be a painting,
it's done that well,
with the cast shadows and the
crumpling figures so well
presented.
Here it's something quite
different, more abstract,
and the stones are not as fine.
You can see they haven't paid
as much attention to getting
them perfectly shaped.
But nonetheless it's very
effective, and it really
does--it does what it intended
to do.
One of the sad things--it's
great to see,
and if you go out to Ostia,
make a special point of seeing
these and taking pictures.
Because I've been looking at
these for many years,
and every time I'm there it
seems that there are fewer
tesserae there--
these are the originals--there
are fewer tesserae than
there were before.
I'm not saying that people take
them,
although I think people do take
but just that over time,
by tourists walking on them
extensively,
they get loose and they get
spread around the site,
and they haven't done as good a
job as I think they should at
Ostia,
in keeping these mosaics
together.
Here's a restored view of the
whole complex,
where I think you can see that,
although the Theater and the
Piazzale are connected to one
another,
and are part of the same
scheme, and are a development,
a further development in
evolution,
that is particularly
appropriate for this commercial
city of Ostia,
that comes out of the orbit of
that earlier theater and
porticus complex at
Pompeii.
We can see that although
they're part of that same
complex, they are distinct from
one another.
If you look at the Theater and
the cavea up above,
with the original wall of the
scaenae frons preserved--
we're looking at it from the
back--you can see that that was
very high.
So only if you were way up at
the top of the cavea
would you really get a sense of
what lay beyond,
and once you got into the
Piazzale over here,
with its temple,
and with its various shops,
you were in another world,
a commercial world.
Also interesting is the fact
that although they're open to
the sky today,
in antiquity there was a
covered colonnade,
as you can see here,
that would have covered those
shops,
and you would have had to go in
between the columns and back
along the passageway in order to
check out what the options were.
The city of Ostia,
like all Roman cities that
we've talked about--
Rome, Pompeii,
Herculaneum,
and so on--
all obviously had a selection
of bath establishments.
Ostia was no exception.
There are a number of baths
preserved, from the Roman city
of Ostia, this being one of
them, the so-called Baths of
Neptune, that dates to 139 A.D.;
the Baths of Neptune,
so called because of the
spectacular mosaic,
black-and-white mosaic,
of Neptune, on the floor.
I'll show it to you in a
moment, but go into it in more
detail a bit later in the
lecture.
If we look at the plan of the
Baths of Neptune in Ostia,
I wondered if any of you can
tell me whether this is a plan
that corresponds to the earlier
bath buildings at Pompeii--
the Stabian Baths or the Forum
Baths--
or conforms more closely to the
imperial bath type that we saw
in Rome,
from the time of Titus,
let's say the Baths of Titus
and Trajan.
Any thoughts?
You grimaced,
but maybe I'll ask you.
Do you have a--pick on you.
Student:  The earlier
one.
Prof: The earlier one,
absolutely.
And why, why do you say that?
Student: Because the
central open area and the
palaestra,
and then the series of bath
rooms.
Prof: Excellent,
excellent, that's exactly
right.
We see the palaestra on
one side, with the
natatio,
or the piscina,
that usually accompanied it,
over here.
And then on the other side,
all aligned in a row,
the typical bath,
the bathing block,
including the
apodyterium,
the tepidarium,
the caldarium and the
frigidarium;
although the frigidarium
is not a round alcoved structure
at all --
so in that sense perhaps
influenced by some of what came
in between those early baths at
Pompeii and the imperial baths
in Rome.
But, and of course also note
here the shops that line the
front of it,
which is also characteristic of
the Stabian Baths and the Forum
Baths at Pompeii.
So they could have chosen the
other,
but obviously felt that this
was much more appropriate to
this commercial town,
to use the smaller,
more intimate bath type here
than the imperial baths that had
been developed in Rome from the
first century A.D.
on.
Just a glimpse of the
black-and-white mosaic that
gives this bath its name,
the Baths of Neptune;
you see Neptune here.
But you can also see the way in
which every room in the bath--
which was made out of concrete,
faced with brick,
as you can also tell from this
view--
every room was covered with
these black-and-white mosaics.
Ostia is the land of the
black-and-white mosaic.
I'll return to that in a moment.
Perhaps most importantly,
of anything that I show you
today, are the apartment houses
of Ostia, and it's to those that
I'd like now to turn.
What you're looking at on the
screen is a model of what one of
these apartment houses would
have looked like.
This one is the so-called
Insula, i-n-s-u-l-a,
of Serapis, the Insula of
Serapis.
And we're looking at it in a
model that is in that museum of
casts that I've referred to a
number of times this semester,
at a place, in a part of Rome
called EUR,
E-U-R, that area that was built
up in the Fascist period by
Mussolini in the 1930s.
This model is in that museum,
and it gives us as good an idea
as anything I could show you of
what one of these apartment
houses looked like in its
heyday,
in the time of Hadrian.
The word insula,
I should mention,
it can be used in two ways.
An insula either refers
to a multi-storied apartment
house, or it refers to a block
of houses in a city like Ostia.
It's used, for whatever reason,
it was used interchangeably to
refer to either a block or to an
individual house.
So pay attention to that when
you read about an insula
or insulae.
Again, this one dates to the
second century A.D.,
the Insula of Serapis.
And it basically was like a
modern condominium,
and often more than one of
these insulae were next,
were clearly next to one
another, but more than one
sometimes shared a common bath.
So they would sometimes build a
bath building that would be used
by those who lived in those two
apartment houses.
Now what's characteristic of
this,
especially as we think about it
in relationship to early
domus architecture,
that we saw at Pompeii,
those single-family dwellings,
is the need in this teeming
commercial city to accommodate a
very large population in a small
amount of space --
people on the whole who could
not afford single-family
dwellings,
who needed to be housed in
these apartment buildings.
They build up vertically,
and, as you can see,
they go up to as many as five
stories,
and we see that the Insula of
Serapis was indeed a
five-storied structure.
It is made out of concrete.
It is faced with brick.
And what is particularly
interesting about the brick
facing here--
and this is going to be our
first example of this,
at Ostia--is the fact at some
point the Romans realized that
brick was really attractive in
its own right,
and it didn't need to be
stuccoed over anymore.
If you think back to the Domus
Aurea,
even in the Domus Aurea,
the building was made out of--
the palace was made out of
concrete faced with brick,
but the façade was
gilded,
and inside, you'll remember,
Fabullus was commissioned to
cover the entire interior of the
structure with stucco,
and then paint it.
So you would have had no sense,
when you were standing in the
Palace of Nero,
in Nero's day,
that it was a brick-faced
concrete structure.
But somewhere along the way,
and it comes to the fore in the
second century A.D.,
they realized:
"Hey, this brick is
actually pretty attractive in
its own right.
It has texture.
We can vary the color;
we can use a reddish brick,
we can use a slightly yellowish
brick.
We can add some stucco,
to make some decorative
effects.
This looks awesome."
And we think some innovative
architects got the idea,
innovative designers,
to "let's leave it,
let's not stucco it over,
let's let it speak for
itself."
And that was a very wise
decision, because as you'll see
today,
the buildings that we have
remaining from Ostia,
that were unadulterated brick
exteriors,
without stucco,
are absolutely magnificent,
and they became,
the designers became real
experts at rendering it in an
extraordinary way.
I think you can get a sense of
that even in this model.
So exposed brickwork here.
You see these arches are made
of bricks that are kind of wedge
shaped and look like the sort of
thing we saw earlier in stone.
Those wedge-shaped sections of
stone that we saw,
for example,
in the Falerii Novi Gate,
we see that sort of thing here.
It may have been used,
just as it was in the Pantheon.
You'll remember how they used
them during the building process
to keep the concrete from
settling before it dried,
but they realized afterwards
that these could be positioned
in a way that made them very
attractive in their own right
ultimately.
We can also see that they have
added moldings,
usually with stucco,
added moldings that make the
building more attractive,
sometimes even little
pediments, as you can see over
some of the windows over here.
So they come up with strategies
to make this brick look even
more attractive than it was on
its own.
Note also the shops in the
first story.
Some of these are shops,
some of these are actually
staircases that lead you to the
uppermost stories.
And once again,
it's clear that the Romans have
become so adept at using
concrete that they are able to
open up these walls.
The openings are larger than
they had been even before,
and so they become very good at
dematerializing the wall in a
way that becomes increasingly
sophisticated over time.
The most famous house at Ostia
is in a sense mine,
because it's called the Casa di
Diana, the House of Diana,
at Ostia.
And we see a view of it here,
as it looks today.
It was a multi-storied
apartment building,
a multi-storied insula.
Only two of those stories are
preserved now.
I'll show you a restored view
of what the original looked like
momentarily.
But we see it here,
as it looks today:
concrete faced with brick,
exposed brick,
brick enjoyed in its own right.
Very large openings that lead
into--they're either
entranceways into the structure,
or lead to staircases,
or open up onto shops.
We can see here in actuality
the same sort of thing we saw in
the model from EUR,
and that is the use not only of
exposed brick,
but also of moldings that are
added,
either in brick sometimes,
or also sometimes in stucco,
of the nice overhangs that they
have created above the
second-story windows,
up there.
We also see a lot of Italian
school children in Ostia,
and Pompeii also,
but particularly Ostia because
of its proximity to Rome,
and all the schools that they
have in the city of Rome;
lots of kids always out in
groups, and they always seem to
have T-shirts of the same color.
So you'll see one red school
and one yellow school and one
blue school;
it's a lot of fun.
And every one of them has
their--it's so funny to me,
they have their cell phones and
they're all clicking,
clicking, clicking,
as they walk through these
buildings.
I'm not sure they're looking at
anything, but they're definitely
clicking, to record the fact
that they were at Ostia;
perhaps that's for student
papers, I don't know.
But here a detail of the Insula
of Diana, looking through one of
these entranceways into the rest
of the structure.
And I'll bet you're as struck
as I am in looking at this,
that with regard to vista,
the interesting panorama and
vista.
It doesn't matter whether
you're building out of rubble or
stone or opus incertum or
concrete faced with brick,
there is that aesthetic,
that Roman aesthetic,
of building things in such a
way that wherever you're
standing in that structure
you're going to be looking from
one part of the building to
another,
and you're going to be struck
by the wonderful scenes that you
see within that building and
from that building,
outside of that structure.
Here's the restored view of the
Insula of Diana,
where you can see that
originally it was a four-storied
structure.
It's a cutaway and an
axonometric view:
four-storied structure.
And this particular restored
view is also extremely helpful
because it shows us that these
houses did not have the
peristyle courts,
or the hortus that we
know from the domus
italica or the Hellenized
domus.
There was no space for that in
this commercial city.
There is no emphasis on the
greenery and the wonderful
fountains and statuary that we
saw in Pompeii.
And keep in mind,
of course, that Pompeii,
in Campania,
was essentially a resort town;
a very different kind of feel
than Ostia, this teeming
commercial center.
So what they replaced those
with here, in order to get more
light into the structure,
is a kind of a light well;
and you see that light well up
here, where there are also
windows on multiple stories.
And, in fact,
I would imagine that those were
the choicest apartments to have,
because they would have been
less noisy than what you can
imagine an apartment along the
street must have been,
with all the activity going in
and out of the thermopolia
and the other shops down
below;
the cart traffic and so on.
So again I imagine the light
well apartment would have been
highly desirable.
Speaking of thermopolia,
we have them at Ostia,
as we have them at Pompeii,
quite a number of them.
And I show you the best
preserved, which happens to be
in Diana's House,
and I show it to you here,
the Thermopolium of the
Casa di Diana at Ostia.
You can see that right at the
entranceway they have put a
black-and-white mosaic.
You see inside just what we saw
at--just exactly the same thing
that we saw at Pompeii,
one of these counters that
would have had recesses in it.
So you have to imagine,
just the same as we saw there,
a kind of fast food emporium,
where you would take a peek at
what looked good for the day,
make your choice.
If you go inside the
thermopolium of Diana,
you see hanging on the wall a
painting,
which it seems likely may have
served as a kind of shop sign
that might have been hung
outside the building to
advertise what you could get in
this particular
thermopolium.
And if we look at what's
depicted here,
it's a still life of objects,
and we see what seems to be a
pomegranate on the right,
hanging on a nail, on the wall.
In the center--I don't know if
you can see it from where you
sit,
but in the center a block that
supports what looks like a
drinking cup that has little
round things floating in it,
lentils or chickpeas or
something like that.
And then at the far left
there's a plate that also is on
a block, a plate that has a
carrot and some other
vegetables.
So this may have been a
vegetarian, I guess this was a
vegetarian restaurant in
Pompeii;
one of the healthier places one
could go, if one wanted a
snack--in Ostia,
excuse me.
If you go to Ostia,
by the way, you really do want
to set aside a day to do that,
because by the time you take
the half an hour ride out there,
get there--there's a lot to see.
And it used to be,
if you'd go there for a day,
which I've done many,
many times, there was
absolutely nowhere to eat.
So you had to remember to bring
your--
and nowhere to get a bottle of
water,
so you'd have to remember to
bring your bottle of water,
and maybe a snack.
But they have rectified that in
recent years;
the last few years they've
finally put up the Caffetteria
degli Scavi,
which loosely translated is the
Excavation Café,
the Cafeteria of the
Excavations at Ostia.
And it's actually a wonderful
place.
I have to say it's very modern.
It has a wonderful deck with
tables and the ubiquitous
Italian white umbrella where
one--and the food is actually,
for a cafeteria,
ain't bad;
Italian pasta is always hard to
make bad, it's always good.
And then inside,
I thought you'd be amused to
see,
when they decided on the
décor for the interior of
the cafeteria,
with its simple tables and
chairs, they put brick on the
wall,
and they then hung up these
wonderful versions of the
Piazzale delle Corporazioni
black-and-white mosaics.
So again, very--Italians are
really,
they do build Ferraris after
all, they are very good at
design and aesthetic,
and pay a great deal of
attention to that,
and consequently always make
one's surroundings pleasant.
Warehouses.
This was a commercial port.
We talked about the fact that
in commercial ports one needs
warehouses.
We began the semester with a
warehouse, in fact,
the Porticus Aemilia in Rome,
along the banks of the Tiber.
And I remind you of that here.
Here's the Tiber,
a model of the Tiber,
with the Porticus Aemilia.
You'll remember that was made
out of concrete.
It was one of the earliest
examples of concrete
construction in the Republic in
Rome: a series of barrel vaults
linked to one another,
on three tiers,
as you'll recall,
with axial and lateral spatial
relations inside that structure.
Ostia needed its own warehouses
as well.
It had them in the Republic
already, but it began to add to
them in the second century A.D.
And it's fascinating to see
what happens when you build a
warehouse out of concrete faced
with brick.
You get an extraordinary
structure that looks very much
like an insula.
If I had put this up and said:
"What is this?"
And you said:
"It's an
insula,"
you would sort of be on the
mark, because it looks exactly
like an insula;
but it is a warehouse.
And this is the most famous
warehouse in Ostia,
the so-called Horrea--because
the word horrea,
h-o-r-r-e-a,
is warehouse in Latin--
the Horrea Epagathiana,
which you have on your Monument
List,
which dates to 145 to 150 A.D.
This is the entrance to the
Horrea Epagathiana.
It is again made out of
concrete, faced with brick;
exposed brickwork,
brickwork enjoyed in its own
right, for its own aesthetic
here.
We can see that it is like the
apartment houses in that it is
multi-storied,
with the large entranceways,
or entranceways into the
structure,
down below, and then the
smaller windows up above.
They have monumentalized the
entrance, the main entrance,
to the structure,
by giving it columns supporting
a pediment.
Very grand, in fact,
and we haven't--
it's interesting to see that
even with this brick-faced
concrete architecture,
the Romans have not lost their
interest in Hellenizing works of
art and using touches of ancient
Greece to monumentalize and to
make more cultured,
in a sense, the entranceway
into this structure.
So we see these columns,
engaged columns,
supporting a pediment above,
capitals on those columns,
as you can see here.
All of this done in concrete
faced with brick.
And you can see here,
this is an outstanding example
of the way in which they have
used brick to their advantage.
They have recognized that you
can vary the color;
you can have a reddish brick;
you can have a yellowish brick.
So here they've used red brick
to face the column shaft,
and then a yellow brick for the
capital.
So there's a distinction
between the shaft and the
capital.
And they have even used the
most expensive material,
marble, for the inscription
plaque,
where they identify this
building at the Horrea
Epagathiana,
and then the pediment above.
And you can see,
if you look at the pediment
decoration and if you look at
the volutes of the capitals,
you will see they have used a
small amount of stucco to enable
them to create the spirals of
the volutes,
for example,
and some of the more delicate
decorative work in the pediment
above.
Another subtlety,
another nice subtlety;
it just shows you the amount of
effort and time and money that
went into this commission.
Also this very nice pilaster
that is placed right next to the
column,
which makes a wonderful
transition from the column,
the roundness of the column,
to the squareness of the
pilaster,
to the shape of the doorway.
The aesthetics very much on the
mind of this particular
designer, as well as the vistas;
again, this idea of looking
through one space,
seeing another opening and
wondering where that opening is
going--
all of that very,
very carefully designed by the
architect.
Here's another view head on of
this elaborate doorway,
leading into the Horrea
Epagathiana,
announcing with the inscription
exactly where you are and what
this building was used for in
antiquity.
A detail of the pediment,
where we can see the
inscription.
We can also see the capitals,
the use of stucco work here,
and the very elaborate work
that they have done to decorate
the pediment above.
Just a few more details of the
columns, where you can see even
better this capital,
and the way in which they have
used brick.
They have used brick even for
the acanthus leaves.
You can see that there are
acanthus leaves here.
This is actually an example,
one of the few we've seen,
of the composite capital,
with the acanthus leaves of the
Corinthian,
and the volutes of the Ionic.
We saw it on the Arch of Titus
in Rome.
But here we see that they've
used brick, and then only at the
uppermost part,
where the leaf has to curve
over, do they add the stucco.
And this is just a warehouse,
and yet a tremendous amount of
effort has gone into making it
an extraordinarily beautiful
building.
And it shows again that they
are absolutely going over the
top, in terms of their being
enamored of what they can do
with brick facing;
that they are now able to
expose.
Once they can expose it,
they're much more willing to
put the effort into it,
to make it really attractive.
And if you go into the
courtyard of the Horrea
Epagathiana--
and by the way,
behind, within these areas
here,
we have annular vaulting--you
can see these niches that have
been placed here.
They don't really need these
niches in this courtyard of this
warehouse.
What did they use these niches
for?
Well perhaps they put little
statuettes of gods that those
who worked here favored and
protected their daily toil here
in the Horrea Epagathiana.
But look at the attention that
they've paid to these niches,
that have no other purpose than
to be attractive,
and possibly again to hold
these statuettes.
But you can see here again,
with this combination of stucco
work for the pilasters and the
capitals, and brickwork;
brickwork creating these
interestingly shaped lozenges
and triangles,
to create--shows an interest
again in geometric form and the
contrast of one geometric form
to another,
just as we saw in
black-and-white mosaic,
capitalized on by these
designers.
Now I don't want to leave you
with the impression that because
brick is now exposed and enjoyed
in its own right,
that there are no walls that
were stuccoed and painted in
Ostia.
That would be a misconception,
because there are still painted
walls in Ostia.
On the insides of some of these
buildings they still opted to
stucco over the wall and to
paint it.
And I want to show you just one
glorious example:
the Insula of the Painted
Vaults,
which dates to 150 to 200,
is one that has one of our best
preserved ceilings,
walls and ceilings anywhere in
a Roman house--
you can see how well preserved
it is here--
and it is what we call the
spoked-wheel effect,
because the ceiling decoration
does look like a spoked wheel.
We can also see this division;
in fact as you look at it,
I think you'll be as struck as
I am by the fact that as we look
at this spoked wheel,
we really get the sense that
we're looking at one of
Hadrian's pumpkin domes in
paint.
Because you can see the
segmented dome effect here,
and also, in a sense,
the octagonal effect that one
also gets from this structure,
as well as the effect of the
ribs of a groin vault,
as you can see well here.
But it's a painted version of a
pumpkin dome,
and it's not surprising to see
that Hadrian's pumpkin domes
took off in this way.
I also just want to mention to
you that while there's a fair
amount of what we call
post-Pompeian painting,
Roman painting after A.D.
79, almost all of it is an
exploitation of the Fourth Style
of Roman painting,
as we know it from Pompeii.
There's actually not as much
invention as one would expect,
after 79, in Roman painting.
I want to show you very briefly
the Insula of the Muses;
the Insula of the Muses in
Ostia, which dates to around
A.D.
130, because this is one of the
few single family dwellings that
we see in the second century in
Ostia.
You can see,
if you look at the plan,
that it is arranged not around
an atrium but around a peristyle
court, here;
although there aren't columns,
there are these piers,
as you can see also in plan.
But just as we saw in the late
first-century A.D.
houses in Herculaneum,
from between the earthquake and
the eruption of Vesuvius,
the triclinium has
become the most important room
in the house.
You enter into it here.
You have a vestibule,
you have this court,
and then you have,
on axis, the triclinium
of the house.
But what makes this particular
house most distinctive is the
fact that every single floor is
covered with mosaic.
So, as I said to you before,
the black-and-white mosaic
reigned supreme in the city of
Ostia,
and it's clear that everyone
who could afford it decorated
every room of their house with
mosaic.
And although this doesn't come
from this particular house,
this comes from the House of
Apuleius in Ostia.
It's not on your Monument List,
you don't have to remember it,
but I just wanted to show it to
you,
because it's a marvelous
example of what can be done--
I wish it were a little more in
focus--
but it's a marvelous example of
what could be done,
and was done,
using black-and-white mosaic in
Ostia;
only black and white
tesserae,
with a Medusa head in the
center.
And then if you--this is one of
those examples,
illusionistic examples,
that as you look at it and
focus on it,
it's hard to tell exactly
what's in the foreground,
what's in the background.
It's got that like an op art
effect that those of you who
know Op Art of the 1960s--
and I show you an example of
it, a painting from the Blaze
series by the Op artist Bridget
Riley of the 1960s.
I've mentioned so many times in
the course of this semester that
there isn't anything that the
Romans didn't do before anybody
else,
and this is,
and Op Art is an example of
that.
So we do see Op Art in Ostia,
and we see it obviously also
much later in more contemporary
painting.
Another bath structure in
Ostia, this one the Baths of the
Seven Wise Men or the Seven
Sages;
dates to A.D. 130.
I show it to you only to show
you this one circular room,
and not because it's a bath
building,
but rather because it has a
wonderful mosaic on the floor;
again, a circular structure,
with a circular mosaic,
once again done in black and
white.
And if you look at this,
you can see that what we have
represented here--
I'll show you a detail in a
moment--
is a flowering acanthus plant
that has intertwined within its
leaves hunters and the hunted,
hunted animals and their
hunters, in combat,
as you can see here.
And here's a detail where you
can see once again done entirely
in black-and-white mosaic:
the hunters,
the animals,
very carefully depicted,
interspersed among these
flowering acanthus plants;
very effectively done.
This is another view of the
Baths of Neptune,
in Ostia, which we looked at
before, dates to 139 A.D.
And this is a good view because
it shows you not only the
brick-faced concrete
construction of these
structures,
but also the mosaics
themselves, and how every single
room of this bath was covered
with black-and-white mosaic.
The pièce de
résistance,
the finest mosaic in the
complex, is this one,
and it's the one from which the
bath gets it name,
the Baths of Neptune,
because we see Neptune himself
in the center of this scene.
It's not surprising that the
god of the sea was chosen as an
appropriate subject for a bath
building.
We see him here with his
trident--that's how we know it's
him--being carried along by four
horses.
He's holding the reins of those
His mantle is billowing up
behind him.
One expects to see a chariot
here;
one thinks of this as Neptune
in a chariot,
but it's not Neptune in a
chariot.
You can see that these horses,
by the way,
aren't fully horses but the
front part is a horse and the
rest is a sea creature,
and you can see that the legs
of Neptune are interwoven with
the tail of the sea creature;
he's in fact using the tails of
those sea creatures almost like
skates,
as he makes his way along
this--or water skis,
I guess is a better way of
putting it;
water skis, as he makes his way
from right to left,
across the white background.
One of the interesting things
about this mosaic is you see the
tension in the minds and work of
this artist,
on the one hand making these
very abstract black shapes
against a white background,
but at the same time paying a
lot of attention to the actual
musculature,
to what the chest of the god
Poseidon would have looked like,
as you look at it;
there's very pronounced
musculature that's carefully
done here by the artist.
Here are our friends the
dolphins frolicking,
dolphins with cupids on their
back,
some fairly--other floating
figures,
a female figure on the back of
another sea creature,
all of this going on,
on the floor of the Baths of
Neptune.
But what's particularly
interesting,
I think, is the same sort of
thing that we saw in the
Piazzale delle Corporazioni,
and that is that the artist has
designed this in such a way that
it doesn't matter which part of
the room you're standing in.
Wherever you are standing,
you can look onto the floor,
from where you are standing,
and see at least some of the
figures head on;
whether you're standing here,
whether you're standing up
there or to the right,
you are always seeing some,
not all but some,
of the figures head on.
So again this is not--this is
done with great care,
and orchestrated to fit the
space in which it was located.
Here a detail of the mosaic
that we just looked at,
showing Neptune and his horses
and sea creatures.
The most important development
that happens at Ostia,
with regard to residential
architecture,
later in its history,
is we do begin to see the
re-emergence of the
domus,
already in the second century
and then even more so in the
third and fourth centuries A.D.
And I want to show you quickly
two examples of that,
because they tell us a good
deal about late residential
architecture in Ostia,
and also by association in Rome.
This is the Domus of Fortuna
Annonaria, an axonometric view
of that house.
It dates to the late second
century A.D.,
but was remodeled significantly
in the fourth century A.D.,
and I think we really need to
think of it as more a
fourth-century house than as a
second-century house.
And, by the way,
Ostia was still thriving in the
third century.
By the year 400 A.D.,
it was abandoned,
but in the third century still
a thriving--and early fourth
century--still a thriving city.
We see this house here.
It's an axonometric view from
Ward-Perkins.
The most important features,
besides the fact that it's a
single-story dwelling,
single-family dwelling,
is the fact that it has an open
court here,
with a pool;
that it has the
triclinium as the most
important room of the house;
so that continues on in
residential architecture.
But there's a particular taste
for apses in these late Roman
buildings.
You can see that this one has
an apse, not so unlike the apse
that we saw in Domitian's
Palatine Palace on the Palatine
Hill.
It is finally starting to catch
on, among others.
We see that you go into that
room through three arches,
on columns.
And this idea of supporting a
triple arch on columns is also a
very popular motif in domestic
architecture in later antiquity.
And look also at the fact that
on the left-hand side of the
triclinium there is a
fountain.
So the incorporation of a
fountain;
a pool court here,
a fountain there,
an apsed triclinium,
and then views through triple
arches,
supported by columns,
all characteristic features of
late Roman domestic
architecture.
This is a view obviously,
through the columns,
supporting that triple arch,
toward the fountain on the left
and toward the apse in the
center of the structure.
And you can see the remains of
marble revetment,
real marble revetment,
that was used both on the
floor, for the pavement,
and also on the walls.
The other house I want to show
you briefly is the Domus of
Cupid and Psyche,
the more famous of the two.
This dates, without any
question, to late antiquity,
to around A.D.
300.
The House of Cupid and Psyche,
we see it first in plan,
and you can see it's very
simple.
An entranceway here,
a long corridor,
a series of cubicula on
one side of that corridor.
There may have been a second
story on a small part of the
house.
You can see the stairway there.
As you walk along the corridor,
you eventually end up in the
very large triclinium.
So again, from the time of the
House of the Mosaic Atrium in
Herculaneum to here,
the triclinium gaining
in importance.
As you walk along that
corridor, you look through a
series of columns,
supporting arches,
as we'll see,
customary of buildings of this
time.
And then look at this wall,
which is scalloped for a
fountain -- so another one of
these fountain courts that seems
to be popular during this
period.
Here's a view into the room
with the lovers,
the famous statue of Cupid and
Psyche, the little young Cupid
and Psyche embracing one
another.
That's from that statue that
the house gets its name.
One of the best-preserved
marble revetted rooms in the
history of Roman architecture is
this room here,
probably the triclinium
in the House of Cupid and
Psyche.
You can see that even marble
from the walls is preserved,
as well as on the pavement and
on the steps and on the side,
the base of the walls as well.
Brick-faced concrete
construction,
faced with real marble.
What makes this particular
house especially appealing,
besides that wonderful statue,
is the fact that although
there's the usual touches of
maroon and green that we tend to
see in many of these Roman
pavements,
most of the color is pastel,
and it makes it look
particularly attractive,
and it goes particularly nicely
with the red and yellow of the
brick construction.
And I show you a detail here,
of that marble revetment,
which gives you as good an idea
as anything I have shown you
this semester of what the
original Hellenistic palaces of
the kings,
the palaces of Nero and
Domitian would have looked like
in their heyday.
And a detail of the statue of
Cupid and Psyche,
and the room in which that
found itself;
it can still be seen there
today.
And the marble revetment once
again done in pastel colors of
the floor,
and of the walls,
giving us again an excellent
sense,
not only of fourth-century
domestic architecture
décor,
but also what so many of the
buildings that are no longer
preserved,
whose revetment is no longer as
well preserved as one would
wish,
what they would have looked
like in antiquity.
A view through the corridor,
through the columns,
in this case grey granite
columns, that probably would
have supported an arcade,
but then without question the
fountain on the side of the wall
that is scalloped,
both down here and the wall
itself,
and then the columns there do
support arches.
So this whole concept of
columns supporting arches,
very much a part of late Roman
house design.
In the very few minutes that
remain, I just want to say a few
words about--we've talked about
the life of this port city.
I want to talk about--since I
said the lecture was about life
and death--
I want to just end with saying
a few words about the tombs in
which the people who lived here
were buried.
People all up and down the
social pyramid lived in this
commercial center.
The simplest tombs--and by the
way,
I mentioned to you already that
there are tombs both outside the
city of Pompeii ,
on the major roads,
and then a little bit further
away at this place called Isola
Sacra,
or the Sacred Island,
where one can see particularly
well-preserved tombs from those
who lived in Ostia of the second
century.
The working poor were buried in
very simple tombs,
of two types.
The upper part of clay
amphoras, just the upper part;
they were broken and then the
upper part was stuck into the
ground.
The remains of the person were
placed below the ground,
and then the spout could be
used to pour wine libations
into.
The other simple type was tiles
that were--
the body was placed below,
and then tiles were arranged
around it,
looking almost like a kind of a
house that helped to protect --
this idea of the houses of the
living and the houses of the
dead,
that were meant to protect the
body.
But most of the tombs are of
what we call the house type.
We looked at the house type on
the Via Appia,
in the age of Augustus in Rome;
a tomb that resembles a house
from the front,
with a doorway,
and a couple of windows,
and then an inscription plaque.
And note the use of the
travertine jambs and lintel
around it, just as we saw in the
Markets of Trajan in Rome.
But if you look at these,
in this very good view from the
side, you will see that almost
all of these are barrel-vaulted
tombs;
which is characteristic of
second-century tomb
architecture,
at Ostia, at Isola Sacra,
these barrel-vaulted structures
with facades that make them look
like houses.
Here's a detail of one of them,
one of these house tombs,
with again the travertine jambs
down below,
with the touch of a pediment up
above--
they haven't lost their
interest in Hellenization to a
certain extent;
windows here, slit windows here;
an inscription,
a long inscription plaque that
tells us who was buried there.
And then very often in these
wonderful tombs for this
commercial center,
these panels that are done in
terracotta that tell us
something about the profession
of those who are buried here.
Here's probably a shipper was
buried here, someone who made
his money in the import and
export business.
And over here you can maybe
barely make out a representation
of a mill,
just as those that we would
have--saw in Pompeii,
or we saw on the Tomb of the
baker Eurysaces;
a mill with a worker and a mule
that is helping to rotate the
mill of the bakery;
so perhaps a baker also from
this particular family.
I've superimposed a couple of
other terracotta plaques,
making them a little larger
here, to show you that these two
belong to people who've made
their profession by sharpening
knives,
knife sharpeners,
and they not only sharpen
knives--
and you can see them both doing
this,
in this scene--but they also
sold them.
And I love the way in the still
life, they're arrayed every
possible knife that you can
sharpen here or buy,
from these individuals.
And what do you think the
professions were of these two?
This one clearly a shop,
someone selling things in a
shop -- looks like vegetables
once again, asparagus and maybe
broccoli or some such over
there.
But what about this one,
what was the profession of this
one?
Student:  Midwife.
Prof: Midwife, midwife.
And I love this,
because here we have this
woman, about to give birth.
She's got another woman holding
her and giving her support.
And here the midwife,
instead of looking at what
she's doing--
she's reaching in,
but she's not,
but instead of looking at what
she's supposed to be
concentrating on,
she's looking out at the
spectator,
just to make sure that we don't
forget her features for
posterity,
on this tomb relief,
from her tomb in Ostia.
We saw columbaria,
these underground columbaria,
with these niches where they
placed the cremated remains of
the deceased and had
inscriptions.
We see the same sort of thing
in the interiors of tombs at
Ostia, but they are above ground
rather than subterranean at
Ostia.
And we also see--and basically
the last point I want to make
today--
is we also see in the interiors
of these tombs at Ostia,
not only those niches for the
cremated remains,
but it's in the second century
A.D.,
the time of Hadrian on,
that inhumation,
burial becomes the norm,
largely under the influence of
the spread of Christianity,
the idea that the soul needs to
ascend to heaven,
and so you have to maintain the
bodily remains.
And so we begin to see in these
interiors what we call
arcosolia,
a-r-c, arco,
a-r-c-o-s-o-l-i-a,
arcosolia,
which are these much larger
niches where bodies are placed,
bodies are buried,
and then they are covered over
with a marble slab that might
have the inscription naming the
deceased,
or a figural scene.
And just in closing,
to show you one last tomb that
we're going to look at next
time,
the Tomb of the Caetennii in
the Vatican Cemetery in Rome,
to show you that these
concrete, brick-faced tombs,
with windows,
and with very elaborate
interiors,
also begin to be put up in
Rome, in the second century A.D.
We'll look at those.
The title of next time's
lecture is "Bigger is
Better";
we're really going to culminate
our move toward larger,
more grandiose buildings then.
And then on Thursday we will
finally move out to the
provinces by studying Roman
architecture in Roman North
Africa.
Thank you.